mesdames et messieurs jean-pierre léaud
il
oui
je suis né à thann en 1959
françois truffaut le plus redoutable des
critiques de son époque présenter
ambitieusement son premier film les 400
coups à la fin de la projection
j'étais porté en triomphe sous un
tonnerre d'applaudissements
et cette année c'est avec un film
d'albert ça la mort de louis xiv
je suis à nouveau à cannes je n'ai
jamais voulu construire une carrière
mais j'ai choisi de tourner avec des
éleveurs
j'aime jean luc besson sera bien sûr
aussi jacques rivette jean eustache
philippe garrel capao l'opa jolie di
bernado staline aussi de belles prochain
agnès dollars mais aussi olivier assayas
bertrand bonello ça je perds on sait
mais niang est évidemment acquis aux
résultats enfin toutes celles et tous
ceux au puy la nouvelle vague compte et
répète le mouvement du nid arte qui
déroule dans le monde du cinéma depuis
50 ans que je
r- descend les marches
je me pose toujours la question d'andré
bazin
qu'est-ce qu'a du cinéma je n'ai
toujours pas réussi à résoudre l'énigme
mais une phrase jean cocteau m'a trahi
ac et l'esprit le cinéma est le seul art
qui capturent la mort au travail on
l'avouera travailler à travers les
acteurs rendre des abeilles à travers
une ruche frère et je crois que c'est
cela qui a su discerner thierry frémaux
en posant son regard sur la mort de
louis xiv et c'est peut être aussi cela
il l'a incité à mains décharnées la pâle
tor m1 les fixies alberta qui faisaient
alors d'honneur du festival de cannes
comme fument toujours dit woody allen
je n'arrive pas à y croire je ne sais
comment remercier thierry frémont mais
je veux que l'on sache que je ressens
aujourd'hui la même joie profonde qui
via 58 ans quand françois m'a dit en me
remettant scénario des 400 coups tiens
jean-pierre pas là le scénario j'ai le
rôle principal merci terry zoom
merci monsieur veut respirer en crau
merci au festival de cannes